atresia of the duodenum is a birth
defect in which the first part of a
baby's small intestine called the
duodenum is blocked located between the
stomach and large intestine
the small intestine absorbs nutrients
from food
the small intestine has three parts the
duodenum
the jejunum and the ileum
the duodenum forms during the sixth week
of pregnancy here you can see the tube
that will become the digestive system
the duodenum grows just below the
developing stomach
the cells inside the duodenum grow so
fast that the tube becomes blocked for a
while later as part of normal
development the cells blocking the
inside of the duodenum die off until the
developing intestine is open again
by about the tenth week of pregnancy for
unknown reasons the outside wall of the
duodenum may not have grown properly
in addition the cells blocking the
inside of the duodenum may not have died
off
as a result a defect called duodenal
atresia forms in which a part of the
duodenum is blocked in one or more ways
it may be blocked by a web of tissue
lining the inside
or a section of the duodenum maybe
completely missing
finally the duodenum may be narrowed
any of these types of atresia prevent
the baby from absorbing nutrients from
milk because the fluid can't pass
through the duodenum duodenal atresia is
not immediately life-threatening but it
will require an operation within a few
days after birth to repair the blocked
duodenum
before the operation a suction tube or
NG inserted soon after birth through the
nose or mouth will remove excess fluid
and air from the stomach
the baby will be given general
anesthesia to put him or her to sleep
for the entire operation
a breathing tube will be inserted
through the nose or mouth and into the
windpipe to help the baby breathe during
the operation
commonly the surgeon will make an
incision under the ribs on the right
side
next the surgeon will carefully find the
atresia or narrow and blocked part of
the baby's duodenum
two incisions will be made in the
duodenum above and below the atresia
the surgeon will use sutures to connect
the two openings
thus bypassing the atresia
finally the surgeon will close the skin
incision with dissolvable sutures or
skin closure strips
after the operation the baby will be
taken to the neonatal intensive care
units for monitoring pain medication
will be given
baby may continue to receive antibiotics
through the ivy
the baby will be released from the
hospital within two to four weeks when
the digestive system is working normally